hello in this video I would talk about
being signaling pathway now the gene
width one was originally named int one
Azzam and it was first identified in
1982 in context of a pro viral DNA which
was injected - which was injected and
found to be forming memory cancer and
the week one proto-oncogene encodes for
a secreted cysteine-rich protein also
parallely it was found in the Flies that
the wingless gene which is very
important for patterning the wing of the
fly is a homolog of wing one genes in
mammal and thereby it's it was named as
winged the int and the Drosophila
weakness now the key component of the
wind signaling pathway is the wing click
and now wing proteins bind to a
homodimer ik receptor complex consisting
of frizzled and alertly five or six now
all the 10 mammalian Frizzle receptors
have seven transmembrane domain and have
large extracellular n-terminal
cysteine-rich domain which help in
binding the wait molecule the wind
feasel interaction is pretty promiscuous
that means a single wings began can bind
to various winter fissile proteins now
in absence of wind in absence of weight
that means the ligand the wind signaling
is absent and no target gene is
transcribed so let us look at what
happens in absence of weight so when
wind is absent there is a scaffolding
protein known as axon which serve to
form as a scaffold in order to make the
destruction complex which ultimately
would degrade peda catenin the second
player and one of the most important
player is a PC or adenomatous polyposis
choline so which was found in camp in
context of a cancer and let
to be an important player in the wing
signaling pathway and it actually
interacts with both beta catenin and
axing sort of work like an intermediate
player and help the beta catenin
to hold into the destruction complex and
thereby phosphorylation of the period
mean there are other two components
which are known as casein kinase 1 and
GSK 3 beta which are selling threonine
kinase so which phosphorylates specific
in terminal residues of peda catenin
once Bill catenin is holed into the
destruction complex by APC and
phosphorylated by GSK through beta the
phosphorylated wing phosphorylated beta
catenin is a target for Peter TRC P
which is a III ubiquity enlightens beta
T RCP transfers ubiquitin chain to the
peer Academy and ubiquitinated beta
catenin degrades by a ubiquitin
proteasome mediated pathway meanwhile in
the nucleus the wind target genes are
bound by transcription factors of PCF
and left family but this DCF a family
transcription factor in absence of beta
catenin bound to groucho which is a
transcriptional repressor and thereby
no-win target genes could be expressed
let us look at what happens when we
Ligon bind to its fizzle receptor will
binding to the fizzle receptors leads to
dimerization of LR 3 5 6 with visit and
dishevelled binds to the fizzle receptor
which leads to instability of the
destruction complex which would which
lead to release of billet happening to
the cytosol
now once beta catenin is released to the
cytosol and APC cannot hold beta catenin
then there is no chance of with
agajanian phosphorylation and thereby
degradation by ubiquitin
you will generated proteasome mediated
pathway so once j ce3 beta cannot
phosphorylate beta catenin BJT RCP
cannot form are you good
chain on beta-catenin and thereby
beta-catenin is not degraded cytosolic
level of beta catenin increases as a
result beta catenin migrates to the
nucleus and interacts with replaces go
Groucho and interacts with TCF left
family of transcription factors also it
recruits CBP and BR g1 which are
transcriptional activators and these
give rise to wind responsive gene
transcription now wind responsive genes
are various types among them one of the
topmost candidate in the list is cyclin
d1 now cyclic d cyclin d1 along with its
partner silica 4 & 6 helps in cell cycle
progression from a g1 to S phase and it
is one of the most important mod
important cycling's for cell division
thereby when signaling is a overall
growth pathway and help in cell division
and proliferation now sometimes what
happens is there is a mutation in a PC
or sometimes a mutation in beta catenin
which leads to constitutive active wind
signaling and as a result there is a
uncontrolled proliferation and which
could be dangerous and which could lead
to cancer
now other targets of the other target
genes of the wind signaling pathways
include C make n make bcl-2 which are
only through up through anti-apoptotic
genes and help in proliferation and
survival now it turns out that wind
signaling is also important for
formation and patterning of the
hippocampus hippocampus which is
seahorse shaped structure in our brain
is important for learning and memory in
absence of wing signaling hippocampus
doesn't form properly when one of the
important wind is wind 3 a and a wintry
and null mutant mice shows aberrant
reformed hippocampus now in other wind
signaling mutants such as left one
mutant it has been seen the dentate
gyrus of the hippocampus is severely
reduced and
also malformed hippocampus that means
wind signaling is one of the most
important player for formation and
proper functioning of the hippocampus
not only that when signaling helps in
differentiation of the noodles so
whenever in a cultured stem cell
population winds the wind signaling is
activated forcefully those neural stem
cells become differentiated neurons so
that's why when signaling could also
help in differentiation of the neurons
not only that when molecules or weak
family molecules has been seen in
several structures of the embryonic
brain and it is quite evident after
decade of research that wind signaling
is important for patterning of the
several aspect of the cortex thalamus
and hypothalamus recently it has been
found that the anterior posterior
nucleus is formed by wind signaling
activity and in absence of wind
signaling or constitutive active wind
signaling there is a spread of one
structure to the otherside so that is
how when signaling is very important for
various aspect of brain development
growth of the Federation and cell
division so that concludes my video on
this topic so if you like my video you
will agree it comes up don't forget to
Like share and subscribe thank you